warning side effects including a new
drug may help the world become a more
compassionate place researchers at the
University of California Berkeley and
San Francisco have found that prolonging
the effects of dopamine on the human
brain gives people a greater sense of
empathy to test the behavioral role of
dopamine when the researchers conducted
a number of neurological tests and even
games the researchers concluded together
these data should lay on the casual
relationships between neural chemical
systems human pro-social behavior all
right not that shocking this must be why
all the kids are doing the molle right
right doesn't the moly do something to
the dopamine I thought it was next to
see that like made molly's a mixture
though right it's not pure ecstasy no
molly is the pure one I think it was
something else I mean yeah drugs there
are drugs that can release chemicals in
your brain that can make you happier and
more empathetic so are we gonna just
bottle all of this one day is everything
just gonna is this brave new world
everything will just be bottled and our
emotions were all coming to pillow form
no I don't even understand why this is a
big deal so yes we have MDMA it actually
works on a serotonin system but we know
that dopamine and serotonin have a
complicated interplay even
norepinephrine when it comes to things
like of the brain or adrenaline and all
of these things have a complicated
interplay when it comes to depression
anxiety happiness sadness all of that
good stuff
dopamine specifically has a lot of
secondary effects so dopamine is also
heavily at play in Parkinson's this is a
drug actually that has been used for
Parkinson's research and part of
Parkinson's treatment so there there can
be totally crazy side effects like
muscular side if that's one years when
you start playing around with these
kinds of drugs but and dopamine also
plays a heavy role in addiction so there
are some dopaminergic drugs that can
actually
you quit smoking for example wellbutrin
has that effect and what's the other
word chantix has that effects but we've
known for a long time I mean that's what
an antidepressant is I take
antidepressants every single day I take
citalopram 20 milligrams every day it's
a it's a selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitor maybe I think any of the side
effects right now because I probably I
get no side effects except that I'm
really tired but see that serotonin it's
not hope for me and what it does is it
allows me to have enough serotonin to
have a functional normal healthy amount
that keeps me from getting really really
depressed
this idea that dopamine aids in empathy
is interesting it's important it is not
a brave new world there are very few
people on this planet that are fully
lacking empathy they're called so this
is why I bring this why I break out
around the show she cleans up cleans up
the science for me yeah had a treatment
for sociopathy that might actually be a
very good thing I wouldn't be afraid of
that yeah we could find sociopathy early
and we could treat sociopathy so that
individuals didn't progress to become
murderers or CEOs right I think that may
be right but then it probably brings up
a whole thing like you could look at
kids who may be more prone to be
sociopath and then you start drugging
them when they're 4 and then what about
their choices in life
it's very close to what we do now right
so are we just a completely over drugged
Society in general we are right I mean
even down to the foods we eat like the
stuff that they put in our foods now has
chemical effects on our brains that it
didn't have 20 or 30 years ago yeah so
just across the board we're taking in if
you're not the kind of person that's
very strict about what you put in your
body when you eat we're taking in all
kind of stuff we don't even know we're
taking in on top of whatever
prescription drugs were taking on top of
that on top of the yeah
50,000 industrial chemicals can be found
in your blood right now that didn't
exist before like a half a century it
goes so this is just about money right
like everything else like why is America
founded this do you have you guys seen
this thing where they looked at what's
in a McDonald's french fry in America
versus versus I think it's the UK and
it's something like in the UK there's
something like four ingredients but in
America there's like 20
legislate against putting this crap in
the food and you were like where's the
money coming from put it in leave it in
if whoever's paying me to lobby on
behalf of this chemical that they need
to put in this fry whatever like go for
it principal that we know of as
regulation yeah and it's quite important
to regulate things to protect people's
health but the truth is what I worry
about is throwing the baby out with the
bathwater I do worry about people going
Oh new drug scary there must be a
nefarious purpose for it all of
Pharmacology is dangerous and evil let's
not even go to the doctor anymore let's
just take herbs into a rain dance this
is a very common progressive view and it
really worries me vaccines are important
medications can be incredibly important
in McCarthy we're in exactly and
life-saving and I think that psychiatric
medications are incredibly important if
you watched going clear science aw the
the just batshit craziness of l ron
Hubbard and his intense fear of
psychiatry and you understand what that
religion is founded in I think that you
appreciate what psychiatry can do for
people a little right not to get too
sidetracked on that but since you've
read the book I'll say it like pardon
that I thought was the most interesting
were there he clearly had message
psychological issues Oh kidnapping his
own daughter and saying to the wife that
he had killed her and all this other
stuff and meanwhile all these people are
following him so I guess there's some
there's some lesson in like religion
totals I know they're yeah but
Scientology is totally founded on a fear
of psychiatry and taxes that's a whole
wing of the Republican Party
all right last thought on this if you
guys had one if there was a pill that
you could create that would do one thing
for you what would it be I would say
make writing jokes easier making the
connections faster and quit like that
would be my I because I love it that's
my thing I love I would say I've had
some success appeal that would make me
just like this all the time and you'd be
okay with the diary and the vomiting and
all the other diarrhea I would be cool
one bill what do you need I mean I take
a pill that has completely changed my
life so I got to get props to that but
to be honest if there were an empathy
pill that if every single person on the
globe could take it would prevent the
the fundamental problems that we all
face which is really come from a lack of
empathy a lack of understanding what
other people are going through
god damn market the [ __ ] out of that
pill get it get it in every mouth in the
globe
that's a quote right there someone make
a gift for price if I could take one
pill it would definitely be that I could
jump high enough to dunk can you dunk
again you can't so I would make every
person on the globe